well I think the truth is as a boy or a
man as a male in this world nothing good
comes to you unless you pursue it and
work for it got to work for it yeah
that's the reality uh I I think a lot of
women don't quite understand this
because women tend to attract things
into their life you can be a woman and
you can just go out there in the world
and be nice and pretty and opportunities
come to you good things come to you
right if you're not repulsive if you're
not rude if you're not you know yeah if
you're Pleasant right like opportunities
will come to you it's still as much as
people want to pretend that you know we
live in this equalist society and men
and women are the same or whatever
absolutely pretty much every woman even
the most Hardline feminist they still
expect the man to be the one who makes
the approach they still expect the man
to be the one the potential sets the
exactly so you know people sort of
cherry-pick between traditionalism and
modernity as it suits them um but I
think the the reality of being a man and
and perhaps the most exciting thing
about being a man is that you really do
get to Choose Your Own Adventure right I
think one of the reasons why men like
video games and like movies and like
these sort of Epic stories is because
you choose it's an adventure right you
you build up your hero you max out your
status and so on so isn't that
interesting that you get to immerse into
the character and think that you're part
of it but you're leveling up a character
in a video game you can be doing it with
yourself in real life yep I I I've made
that point several times especially with
guys who are really into gaming yeah I'm
like man why don't you treat your life
like a role playing game right but it's
for real right you're spending all this
time leveling up in the game building
your strength stat building your
endurance stat building your charisma uh
earning magic fake money in the game I'm
like man you know you could do you know
the one I found this funniest with is do
you remember when um the Guitar Hero
games and Rock Band games were super
popular yeah I used to do the rock band
stuff
yeah and people would spend hundreds of
hours learning how to master a fake
guitar I'm like bro you know with the
time and effort you're putting into this
you could learn how to play a real
electric guitar yeah you could go out
with your buddies and start a band and
actually like gig and tour and sell
merch and do some cool stuff and get
it's actually really really hard to play
a guitar well I got Rocksmith after
after rock band and you get a real
guitar and you plug it into your console
and it and it teaches you how to play
the guitar
and my hands don't move you know the way
they need like I just can't get them to
move maybe it's from bodybuilding and
and and grabbing bars so [__] hard
that I just can't like I don't have the
dexterity but with rock band oh no
problem I can play that guitar all day
long on hard mode
right yeah but I just think when you
when you think of like the amount of
time and effort and dedication that
people put in like there's guys who put
hundreds thousands of hours into
mastering some random video game and you
know it's one thing look king of theill
video game yeah you know these days you
can make a living off it right so if
you're out there and you know you're
making hundreds of thousands or Millions
off of playing uh you know Quake or
OverWatch or whatever it is then oh man
props to you you know good good for you
but the vast majority of people are not
so I'm not even here saying like hey
guys you know cut out video games right
no video games or any I'm just like man
don't let that be don't let that be
better than your reality don't be using
this as just a form of escapism and
procrastination and instead of leveling
up your character in the real world and
traveling to cool places in the real
world and meeting cool people in the
real world and building all of these
stats like just doing it in the game I'm
just like hey man you've already got the
obviously there's something in you that
already has that mindset so just go out
there get out of your house and do it
for real in the real world and sometimes
it it sounds kind of funny but that is
how I view my own my own life sometimes
right especially I quit my job in 2011
and for the past 12 years I've really
just been on this adventure man I've
been to hundreds of cities dozens of
countries I've met hundreds of thousands
of people I'm working out I'm building
my strength stat I'm doing these
podcasts and public speaking I'm
building my Charisma and my
communication skills building my network
building my net worth whatever it is and
I'm like man this is cool I can just
create I can create my reality I can
choose what country and city I want to
live in I can choose who I want to
associate with I can uh I can purchase
new things I can try this I can try that
and I'm just like man that's the that's
the adventure of a man's life and I
think that all if you think of all the
any famous story it doesn't matter
whether it's from a religious text or
it's a legend or it's a fairy tale or
it's a Disney movie or it's a superhero
movie they all kind of have the same
plot they all kind of have the same plot
I'm just like yeah and I'm like man
every man has the potential to have that
you can have that you can create that
for yourself and it's pretty cool to do
it I really hope you guys enjoyed that
clip if you want to watch the full
length podcast you can find that over
here that clips from if you're new to
the channel make sure you hit subscribe
over here and pin down below in the top
comment you'll find a bunch of useful
links to my website my supplement line
books and a bunch of other stuff have an
amazing day peace out